[Musique]
bienvenue dans le quartier général des p
ça veut dire les petits plis existe
patates on a cherché partout sur la
montagne on rêvait d'en trouver un et ce
jour est enfin arrivé
c'est typique bon sens c'est un petit
pied il est partout on cherche dans ta
mémoire il a été emporté par le vent au
dessus des nuages et vous vers le haut
c'est le côté vers le corps vers le bas
eh oui joe68 il est encore là pour
m'aider si elle garde le tenait en bas
tu sais que tu dois essayer mais je t'ai
vu tu as forcément mal vu lego tu sera
bannie de notre village tant que tu ne
seras pas prêt à nous dire la vérité je
sais ce que j'ai vu et je vais le
prouver
c'est trop tard pour avoir des doutes si
tu meurs je peux avoir tout est bien
terrestres mais pardon quand tu m'auras
c'est parti aïe
non
et veufs testera du soir bonsoir
je m'affiche
non je tombais de chez moi
[Musique]
on sera en sécurité bien au chaud une
minute caisse alors ça va et bien
réchauffé de tous les côtés qu'est-ce
qu'il ya ça va pas t'as faim tu y
injectons casse croûte
[Musique]